still remember the two-hour wait and the
gut feeling that something had gone
terribly wrong
a year ago on June 5th they had received
a radio message from their colleague
indigenous expert Bruno Pereira he was
on his way to meet them at the small
River Port of atalaya donoche British
journalist Don Phillips was accompanying
him in the boat
when they didn't show up I knew
something horrible had happened we set
out with our indigenous Patrol team to
try and find them
had been heading indigenous patrols
documenting invasions by poachers in the
javadi territory home to the world's
largest number of isolated tribes ten
days after the search began the bodies
of both men were found they had been
burnt dismembered and buried a few
months before the assassination we had
witnessed an encounter between perida
and Amarillo Da Costa Oliveira one of
the two fishermen who confessed to the
murder
both men are now in prison in a weight
trial the brutal killing of Dom Phillips
in Bruno Pereira Drew worldwide
attention to the remote and sleepy town
of atalaya donochi people here thought
that things might change but you can
still feel the tension
was a key witness in the murder trial
says he fears for his life and he's not
the only one
illegal fishermen still into the
indigenous territory and they're still
being financed by criminal organizations
but in the years since the murders
Brazil's government under recently
elected left as president Louisiana
has very publicly announced steps to
protect the region from poachers local
leaders Say It Isn't Enough
this member of the korubu tribe told us
his Scouts had caught a poacher on his
lands they tied him and took him to the
local authorities but he was set free
you know
next time the poachers show up we will
have to act on our own if we don't want
to be killed
all sides agree that policing an area
the size of Austria presents enormous
challenges but one year after the
killings of Dom Phillips and Bruno
Pereira residents of the Javari Valley
insist those challenges must be met to
ensure that no more lives are lost
foreign